as people watched the the vehicles drive
around men
troll
particularly boss seem to be on the
street how far off is this technology
from use in everyday vehicles some of
the technology and boss are already in
cars if you want to you by those are
examples like keeping distance from a
next vehicle during automated cruise
control a parallel parking commercial
feature it's not whether the features
will reach cars it's just how they get
into the market a little bit at a time
the commercialization has gone on for
years and will continue forever in cars
it's not that like the Big Bang creation
of the universe where nothing happened
nothing happened and then it's all there
automated cars occur in inch at a time
the University of course is proud of the
team do you think this will have an
impact on carnegie mellon university
every great robot adventure has a
favorable effect at carnegie mellon when
Dante went into the volcano applications
go up quality profiles go up and lots of
people want to come here male is pouring
in from around the world about people
from India and China
the Singapore and Europe who want more
of what we've got so what's next for all
the for all the wonder of the urban
challenge the past becomes the past
pretty quickly the urban challenge is
history next up is the moon the google
lunar xprize offers 25 million for a
good robot to deliver a broadcast from
the moon that sounds like it has our
naval in it we're going to go get it